[Musique]
tout garde-manger qui se respecte
contient des tomates en conserve
j'ai coupé 5 c'est particulièrement vrai
dans les familles italiennes
aujourd'hui mais norman cette zone en
septembre là famille verhille où se
rassemblent pour la corvée annuelle de
conserves de tomates
elle perpétue ainsi la tradition
familiale les petits après mamma de
madame tomates
bon an mal an il met en conserve 100
litres de sauce tomate qu'il utilise
toute l'année durant pour garnir leur
plat de pâtes
la magie ce passé en plein mois de
décembre en côte ou son premier peau de
tomate sont le jardin à travers ce au
restaurant la récolte la chef
lissa bagheera elle aussi d'origine
italienne prépare des conserves de
tomates entières qu'elle considère comme
plus polyvalente pour les sortir cet
hiver on peut faire dd avec on peut les
tranchées en deux pour refaire des
tomates heures au dessus on pourrait
dépasser pour faire une sauce sont
offerts le jus directement donc pour les
tomates entières au port avec la tomate
c'était important d'aller monde à les
enlever ici la petite partie du
pédoncule vie on fait une petite croix
en dessous se passer le patcher donc on
essaye de ne pas aller très profondément
dedans
on immerge d'abord les tomates dans
l'eau bouillante de 30 secondes à une
minute par petites quantités en enfin on
veut juste précuire la tomate on veut
que la peau commence à lever un petit
peu puis en fait si on veut altérer la
tomate le moins possible en fait c'est
comme s'il a conservé un peu crue dans
le coup l'apu commencé à lever avec eux
on va l'enlever pour un vus la peau
c'est facile on a fait une croix en bois
tantôt donc on y va soit au couteau
comme ça où on est donc nos tomates son
monde et on est prêt à les mettre en pot
ce qui est important pour les possédait
bien les stériliser évidemment donc mais
les tomates en essayant de ne pas
toucher le bord en essayant aussi
d'avoir le moins pas ses besoins selon
moi les écrans 20 plus donc on essaye de
vraiment remplir super bien le plus
possible peau pour avoir le moindre
espace puis que les tomates prennent le
plus de place dans le pot
comme les tomates ne sont parfois pas
assez acide pour empêcher la
prolifération de bactéries et la
formation de gaz qui provoque
l'explosion dépôt il est essentiel
d'ajouter du jus de citron ou du
vinaigre
les autorités nous suggère deux
cuillères à soupe par les trop de
conserve
lise ajoutent aussi une cuillère à thé
de sel les couvertes le neuf sont placés
dans l'eau chaude
on veut leur hameau l'epo qui adhère
vraiment bien qu'en mai les bagues
on va tourner là ça s'est fini le entier
ont bien atteint un degré ou est-ce que
sa selle donc on a put besoin de tourner
on place les pots dans une grande
marmite avec une grille au fond ou comme
ici des bacs de métal l'idée est qu'ils
ne soient pas en contact direct avec la
source de chaleur se dit mido tempéré
pas trop chaude ni trop froide on veut
aller jusqu'à infos sont moins par
dessus l'épaule voilà on part ça et
quand ça va bouillir on va compter 25
minutes
on utilise une pince en caoutchouc pour
sortir les pots dans la tradition
italienne
on laisse tempérer les pouces ou une
couverture afin qu'ils refroidissent
lentement à l'abri des courants d'air
moi je laisse comme c'est généralement
la couverte un format de 4 48 heures et
ensuite je vais vous répondre
ces tomates entières vous serviront
toute l'année lui fait la même chose
chaque année il parle mais il travaille
pas c'est tout moi qui coupe les tomates
pour la base de sauce tomate italienne
traditionnelle
une fois lavés et coupés et égouttez les
tomates sont ensuite passés au
prestement
on fait ensuite mijoter 45 minutes y'a
pas grand chose c'est joli j'ai besoin
de toi c'est avec tournée son
propriétaire que julie a appris il ya
trois ans à faire des conserves de
tomates à l'italienne sauf que j'ai ma
petite variante
quand tu mets quoi n'était rien fait
pour m'assurer que le ph est bien stable
je mets
du jus de citron la première fois que
j'ai fait des tomates avec tony lui
avait on chantonne avec ses tomates mais
moi à chaque semaine j'avais eu une
explosion qui arrivait d'un mot dans mon
garde manger donc l'année d'après j'ai
fait mes recherches que j'ai ajouté
cette variante le mais sinon je pense
qu'à travers la mise en conserve des
tomates une activité festive a réalisé
en groupe à côte
gratuit
[Musique]